but has evolved both in terms of
parameters in terms of some of the
details of the sectors but the structure
is basically the same as it was in 1992
and the structure of the model is shown
in the figure here I'll just describe it
briefly you have economic growth leading
to emissions on the upper left and
that's from our driving or heating or
cooking our airplane dharia travel this
leads to rising co2 concentrations and
other forces leading to climate change
and climate change is not just
temperature but it's precipitation and
sea level rise and many other processes
and then that to the next arrow it has
impacts or it has impacts ecological
impacts economic impacts lower corn
yields coastal flooding ocean
acidification which is actually the
other carbon dioxide problem which I
won't talk about very much but it's bad
for crustaceans and then the next is so
the next link is climate play and change
policies to reduce emissions and these
would be through different mechanisms
such as cap-and-trade which you know
here in Europe but carbon taxes which
you know in Sweden regulations which all
countries know and then that then
through the policies leads back up to
affecting emissions reducing emissions
and then affecting more you know a
greater or lesser degree climate
economic growth itself and I put those
arrows there to see India and the first
two errors are ones we know about and
actually exist the other two we don't
actually all lives don't actually exist
in all cases so this is the lot this is
the circular flow that is part of the
modeling that we're talking about today
so I want to say a word see what we're
doing here I was saying a word about
mathematics for just a little bit of
mathematics as a language particularly
for people for young people and students
and
who are thinking about what they're
gonna study my first teacher and and
mentor and co-author Paul Samuelson was
also the first American laureate in
economics and he was responsible for the
introduction of mathematics into
economics and his view was mathematics
is necessary if we were to understand
and analyze complex phenomena and it's
something that point is now part of my
brain it's it's actually built in just
as much as the English language is it's
it's is part of my brain and it's an
interesting the the great American
physicist John Willard Gibbs in a Yale
faculty meeting when there was debate
about foreign languages he stood up and
he said mathematics is language and he
sat down and and he's write the language
and that language is increasingly part
of our lives it's from the design of the
computers that are running this the show
here to our power plants to the medical
scans that save our lives and I think
mathematics is our future that's all I
mean I think we need to study foreign
languages we need to study all kinds of
things poetry art but mathematics is is
key to so many areas of our future the
math the language of mathematics is also
simple to our modeling of climate change
economics I'll just show you a little
picture here I thought I'd show you the
mathematics of the model and here it is
that's all that's all it is it's a
maximization constrained maximization
problem it's comes simple so there's a
lot of vectors here and times and
integrals and so on and it'll be
discretized for the actual computerized
model but any of you who know the
modeling and know mathematical economics
will say oh yeah that's just that's a
simple old growth model that we know and
love for so many years ago and those of
you know mathematics will say well
that's kind of interesting and those of
you don't just view it as a it's just
it's a counterpart of goya it's just a
picture here okay maybe not so
frightening I don't know maybe more
frightening but don't don't be
frightened don't be frightened so
economists are focused on the strata so
let me just turn out of
to a little bit of the actual results so
economists have focused on the economist
and others have focused on strategies to
slow climate change and they're
basically three potential strategies
abatement or reduction of emissions is
the one I'll focus on the second one is
removing carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere which would be run wonderful
but actually you could grow trees to do
that for example but but well I won't
say but and then there's management of
sotell solar radiation through say
putting dust in the stratosphere
abatement the first one I mentioned is
the only realistic and safe option at
present others may come along but at
present it's all that we have so I'm
going to concentrate there but I have to
say while realistic it's also expensive
particularly in if we are ambitious and
just to give an example in a common goal
of the international negotiations and
policies is to limit temperature to two
degrees C above pre-industrial levels
and estimates are that that would might
cost about 4% of our income over the
next next century or two this may be
good for nature but it's it's not
actually all that attractive to voters
to reduce their income that sharply so
it shows some of the trade-off
now that's abatement I'll say a word
about just a word about damages because
in our economics what we're going to do
is weigh the costs of reducing emissions
and slowing climate change or limiting
temperature on the one hand with the
reduction in damages on the other so we
have to you have to go out and do the
modeling you have to determine what the
damages are and you might say well
that's impact sound easier because our
debate mentor you need the physics and
the chemistry and all that but actually
damages damages is just
comics and ecology but actually damages
are much much more difficult and it's
probably the most difficult task in all
of our processes that were on that last
slide because it's so far in the future
the things we don't understand very well
there we don't have historical
experience of this so it's actually
probably the most difficult so what I'll
do is I'll show you some illustrative
results I suppose these slides will be
available so that they will be available
let me I guess they will be available on
the website so some of you I know this
goes by very fast but some of you who
want to look at them in detail can go
back and and find them but I want to
show you an example of the results from
the the dice model and this I want to
emphasize this is only one of many
models there there are people in the
room who do who do I won't point you out
but you know who you are who are doing
my other models and they're they're
wonderful models and people around the
world who are doing this the only reason
I present well the main reason I
presented is cuz I know it but also it's
a simple model has a virtue of
simplicity and comprehensiveness in the
sense that it does close that all the
boxes the links in that and another
model some do and some don't but I would
emphasize that these are very simplified
models and so for example the climate
sector two equations whereas if you go
to some of the large climate models
they'll have a million equations and so
these are very very these don't have the
resolution of the most the most
comprehensive and up-to-date models so
he let me give me so I want to talk
about four sets of policies and I'll
just mention these briefly one is what a
business-as-usual which is basically no
policies or minimal policies a second
one is where you balance the costs and
the benefits a third is where you limit
temperatures over time to say one and a
half degrees which is the latest
objective or two degrees or two and a
half degrees and a third is my
modification of that where you don't
limit it as an absolute cap but you're
limited over an average period
that actually makes more sense because a
lot of processes are function of
averages rather than just the absolute
level at a point of time so those are
the four that I'll I'll show you some
results from so one is you you take
these and I'll just one other thing so
you take this business as usual what
happened and then let's say if you want
to limit the temperature to two degrees
C which is in the third bullet there how
can you do that most efficiently so it's
not just any old way but if that you've
got cost of doing it and you've got the
systems and you want to find how can I
limit it to two degrees in the way
that's the most cost the least costly
and in the economic sense so here's a
here's a picture that shows it's a
little it's a little crowded but I'll
give you a quick rundown so the top so
on the this is time from 0 to I've gone
to 2150 just to give it a little further
depth and this is then from 0 to 6
degrees C above pre-industrial we're
already at about 0.8 0.9 so in and this
shows you different paths doing this on
the top path is if we do nothing and you
can see that just keeps climbing and
it's it's pretty pretty substantial by
the 20 120 150 and then there are other
paths there's one that have say economic
cost-benefit path where you balance
costs and benefits and then there's this
green one where you limit it to two
degrees C and then some of the other
ones are where you limited say two
degrees C with the 200-year averaging
two degrees C with a 100 year averaging
or one and a half degrees with the one
your 100 your averaging they all look
pretty much this so if you go out and
you they actually don't look very
different for quite a while and then
they begin to diverge after 2050 or so
but they have very different paths but
the main thing I'll show you is actually
if you take steps now to implement these
you have quite different futures from
very very high temperatures on the one
hand to relatively low for the
for the temperature limiting paths the
next slide I want to show you it shows
you the of the economics of this so the
Green Line the green bars show you and
don't worry too much about the the the
units here on the left they're their
present values but but they're just the
bars or what I want to emphasize on so
you can see the damages from doing
nothing to the optimal to the
temperature limiting and the damages
obviously as you limit temperature
increase the damages are going to go
down from from left to right and these
are increasingly stringent policies from
left to right increasingly ambitious
policies and then so the damages go down
but then what are the costs well they're
not not much cost if you don't do
anything but as you become increasingly
ambitious the cross rise and so you
wanted what economics says well how are
you going to balance these and if you if
you were if your manukan see that the
extremes you have a lot of damages and
no cost at one extreme and a lot of
costs and very little damages or the
other and somehow in between you can
balance the two and what you wanted to
think of in economics or in more
generally is what's the best balance
between these two is that the optimal is
it a two degree is a averaging period
what different averaging period so you
want to find some balance between the
costs and the benefits of the damages
now economics yep so economics points to
one inconvenient truth about climate
change policy and that is to be
effective the policies have to raise the
price of carbon or co2 and by doing that
correct the externality of the
marketplace and so one of the I think
one of the insights of economics I feel
very strongly about is if you're going
to be effective you have to raise the
price because putting a price on our
activities is the only way I mean we
have to we have to get billions of
people
in now and in the future millions of
firms thousands of governments to take
steps if we're going to move in the
direction we want and the only way that
you're going to do that effectively is
to increase the price of carbon and I
would say something about the history of
that because is I think it's an
interesting scientific story the idea on
carbon pricing flowed from the research
on what are known it technically is dual
variables in linear programming from the
pioneering nearing work of Ken aerobic
and Koopmans for which then they won the
Nobel Prize in 1975 and it's if you do
this the optimization I showed you a
little earlier and you just rock and
grind and you just grind through it and
you look what we used to be computer
printouts we don't have those anymore
you would see the dual variables there
and I remember when I looked at I just
scratched my head I had no idea what
this dual variable and the carbon
constraint was and there were different
ones on different different different
reservoirs and then eventually I
realized and I'll quote when when I
first realized this is what I what I
wrote in 1977 and it's it's I haven't
gone much further than this because of
the externalities there are no market or
political mechanisms which ensure that
the appropriate level of control will be
chosen to implement the efficient path
implies that we are implicitly putting a
positive price on emissions of carbon
into the atmosphere quote carbon taxes
as a way of implementing the global
policy on a decentralized level so that
that that that was the first time it
really occurred to me that to think of
this in this way and so what basically I
it is evolved over time and i won't i
won't spend much more time on the
I'll just mention that this actually
disappeared for a long time and then
re-emerged about 20 years later in the
idea of the social cost of carbon which
is how much it costs to put a ton of
carbon in the atmosphere and that's
actually central now to national
policies it's central to the design of
carbon instead of climate institutions
as a setting a carbon price or carbon
tax so over the years nations have
negotiated many international climate
treaties the Framework Convention the
Kyoto Protocol the Copenhagen Accord the
Paris Accord how are we doing you might
ask how are we doing we-we is the carbon
price where it should be or is it lower
or higher you know the answer that
question is that the world carbon price
is nowhere near where anyone thinks it
ought to be it's maybe 1/10 of the most
modest estimate of the social cost of
carbon the actual global carbon price is
essentially zero and I I'm not going to
go through the various proofs of that
but I want to talk about what why that's
a problem and what we might do about it
enough so as I think about this the the
read the problem here is the that these
treaties have been ineffective in
limiting carbon emissions I'll just show
actually I'll show you one graph here
which is the trend in global emissions
from 1970 to 2017 policies have been
really ineffective in dealing with
climate change and the reason is because
of free riding and freeriding is where
you receive the benefit of collective
activity collective action without
paying the cost without contributing and
the case of international climate policy
what it means is you you get the
reduction in down
due to people's efforts but you don't
have to do any costly steps at home and
so I'll just talk that's the free rider
problem in economics in climate change
so in in research on this issue and
following much the brilliant studies of
the economics of treaties and game
theory I came to a solution that I
called a climate Club and want to talk
about that in my last three minutes so
what is the idea of a climate club the
idea that nations can overcome the
syndrome of free riding in international
agreements if they adopt the the model
of a club and a club is an agreement
where you you know what clubs are we're
all in clubs of various kinds but
they're also international clubs as the
club of the EU to which you which you
remember there's the club of NATO which
you're not a member but the Sweden is
not a member but is a beneficiary
there's the club of the World Trade
Organization of which we're all
beneficiaries and the idea for club here
is to change the way we think of
international agreements which are
essentially voluntary for climate to
make them ones where you you not only
benefit but you pay and for the example
that I'll suggest is an international
climate Club to overcome free-riding is
the idea is that you would have club
played ooze through abatement but
members but non-members are penalized by
having tariffs on their imports into the
club region and so let's say you set a
target carbon price of $50 a ton then
nations would have their domestic price
through whatever mechanism they would
choose at $50 a ton but if you weren't a
participant then you would have a
penalty attack a penalty tariff into the
club region so the dues or abatement
and penalties are the tariff and I'll
just show you a very simple example this
is from my presidential address to the
American Economic Association and it's a
very simple idea here the bars from left
to right are the tariff rates of a club
there are 15 regions in this and the
height of the bar is how many
participants there are as a function of
each tariff level and the first tariff
level is zero and that's the basic
structure where there's no penalty to
non participation and they're no
participants but in this simple example
for a $50 tonne as the tariff rates gets
up to three four five percent you see
more and more nations participate and
then is high enough all nations
participate so we're obviously a long
way from the climate club or analogous
arrangements but I think that I think
that we should we should look at this as
a kind of model for future going forward
so I think I'll just wrap up here and
I'll just make four points to end up
where do we need to go next
first we need to accept and understand
the gravity of climate change scientists
must continue their research and
citizens must reject politicians who
spread falchion tendentious reasoning
that's a very important step we must
establish policies that raise the price
of co2 and other greenhouse gas
emissions
we must act locally and nationally both
actions must also be coordinated on a
global level and it that's it
and it's clear that finally that we need
rapid technological change in the energy
sector for the transition so this
concludes my discussion of the economics
challenges posed by climate change
and I would emphasize the solution
ultimately lies in harnessing human
ingenuity to develop and deploy
low-carbon technologies and with that
thought with that thought I'd like to
turn to the extraordinary insights on
the economics of technological change
that have been developed by my fellow
laureate Paul Romer so listen up thank
you
[Applause]
before before we get back to Paul Romer
Paul you're there let me pick up just
briefly on the Sweden Norway so in the
spirit of brotherly love as we call it
and and in the spirit of Alfred Nobel
actually I would like this game to end
1-1 so we need to have award Sweden and
now the point and I I think I've chosen
to give it for producing less fossil
fuel than Norway but Paul Romer was born
in 1955 in Denver Colorado he received
his PhD from University of Chicago but
unlike professor Nora house Paul moved
around quite a bit
University of Rochester back to
University of Chicago University of
California Berkeley Stanford University
New York University where you're
currently the research question there as
we already know now was about this other
resource knowledge and in particular
knowledge how it's ever advanced in
market economies not in at universities
obviously it's advanced here as well but
in market economies and I said that
knowledge accumulation in the form of
new technologies is absolutely crucial
for us and we've heard it's crucial in
this particular area as well so the key
step here was the development of what is
now ubiquitous Lee called endogenous
growth theory please ladies and
gentlemen Paul Romer
I too will rely on technology and and as
that there's a designated advocate for
technology you can count on it failing
me at some point during the talk so
thank you pair for framing the work that
bill and I have been engaged in in such
I think an appropriate way it really is
the global macro economics of the
tension between the restraining force of
scarce resources and the positive force
that can come from discovery and
innovation let me ask you to thank all
the members of the committee for
highlighting the connection between
these two forces the restraining and the
positive and it's the balance of these
two that will determine our fate thanks
as well to the many friends and
colleagues and to the members of my
family who can all be here today I let
me save my appreciation for the vision
of Alfred Nobel and for the foundation
that continues to keep his vision alive
let me save that for my conclusion
so lately lots of people have been
asking me why exactly I won the Nobel
Prize in Economics my task once again is
to try to explain and I'll do my best
but one of the things I learned from my
father who's here in the front row as
who spent his life as a politician is
that the key to success is to manage
expectations so let me warn you that I
have trouble explaining why I think
technological change is
Oh compelling and so subtle when my son
Jeff was seven or eight he asked me what
kind of work I did as a professor I told
him well I'm trying to understand why
your grandparents when they were
children didn't have access to the kinds
of things that you have like a video
cassette recorder Jeff looked at me and
said dad that's obvious
when nanny and granddad were kids the
video cassette recorder hadn't been
invented yet is there anything else from
your work that I can help you with so
today I'll start by trying to describe
this notion of the possibility of
progress and explain why when I was in
graduate school in 1980 there were so
many doubts about whether progress was
possible whether this positive force of
discovery could offset the tension the
restraining force of the the scarce
resources then I'll describe the theory
I developed the trance show that
progress is indeed possible at least in
principle I'll turn after that to the
description of two practical suggestions
that emerge from this theory analogous
to Bill's suggestion about the carbon
tax mindful as I am that Alfred Nobel
stipulated that prizewinners be judged
on the benefit they confer to humankind
not just on the scientific merit of
their discoveries so when I was in
graduate school in 1980 I think there
were at least three distinct forces that
were undermining confidence about the
possibility of progress one was a
growing list of negative side effects
from unanticipated negative side effects
from what seemed like positive
technological discoveries one of the
most interesting was a discovery by
sherlyn Rowand and
melina that chlorofluorocarbons could be
destroying the ozone layer a discovery
for which they received the Prize in
Chemistry in 1995 but there were this
was their paper on this was in 74 but at
this point we had also seen problems
with DDT the damage that was done to
human health by leaded gasoline even the
cancer that was caused by cigarettes so
it seemed plausible that that positive
force of discovery might not turn out
even on its own to be so positive
because of the unexpected negative side
effects it was also the case in 1980
that people had lost faith in the
government to do the very basic jobs
that we expected of the government the
throughout the 70s there had been this
steadily increasing rate of inflation
we'd had recessions that caused
unemployment and moved inflation down
but still to a relatively high level so
we referred to the new experience is
that of stagflation but the really
disturbing fact was that from one
recession to the next
the general trend was for a steady
increase in the underlying rate of
inflation now finally my undergraduate
degree was in physics and from economic
theory the only theory of growth that
made any sense to a physicist was the
one developed by Thomas Malthus it
starts from an invertible
incontrovertible premise that there's a
finite quantity of every natural
resource using only simple arithmetic it
then follows that there is no
possibility of sustained progress let me
use copper as an example of a natural
resource the total mass of copper on
earth and the Earth's crust is finite
think of measuring that in kilograms
for every person in the earth the total
number of people you divide kilograms of
copper by people you get a certain
amount of copper per person even if we
don't use copper up because we transform
it but it still exists
there's no way to increase the total
supply of copper available per person
that we can use to do things like
provide electricity so there's no
possibility of progress if it takes more
of something like copper per person to
make progress and if we see a pattern of
progress it's it's very easy to
reconcile that with this scarcity
because it could be a sign that we're
depleting the untransformed
stock of copper and Earth's crust we're
depleting that using more and more per
person but were soon headed to a the
wall we won't be able to keep extracting
more and more copper and when we hit
that wall it was equally plausible that
we might not just slow down but we could
really face a collapse
now I was focused primarily on the trend
I was looking at history and saw this
progress over 10,000 years that seemed
hard to justify is just a temporary
phenomenon that would soon come to the
end but the Malthusian theory has
another implication not about the trend
but what about what economists refer to
as a scale effect what's the effect of
having more people say at a point in
time
suppose you have twice as many people
here to the the the conclusion is very
grim twice as many people means half as
much copper per person it's just
arithmetic now Homo sapiens emerged
during the Pleistocene in an era when
this Malthusian Theory applied with full
force and key elements of human nature
were shaped by this experience the one I
want to emphasize is the pre-decision
predisposition we have to group people
into us and them them is a group that
poses an existential threat to us they
might steal our resources there are also
an opportunity we might be able to steal
their resources from them and even if
all we do is share there's less for us
when there's more of them now Donna
Strickland who was one of these years
prize recipients in physics told me that
when she was president of the optical
society she was part of the planning for
the International Year of light one of
the goals they emphasized was the
eradication of light poverty now this is
a figure but a picture that I've never
forgotten when since I've saw it many
more than a decade ago what it shows is
some students studying under
streetlights outside the airport in
Conakry Guinea
now this conveys just instantly that the
human consequences of light poverty they
can't do their homework at home it also
suggests this obvious fact about
technology we know how to provide light
in homes why don't we use that
technology to provide light in the homes
of these these students but there's an
emotion that can be invoked by this
picture which also relates to this
Malthusian fear about us in them with
existing technology if we were to
provide them the same access to
electricity that we have this would lead
to more emissions of carbon and could
threaten the planet so although it's not
always voiced there is a realistic
perception it seemingly realistic
perception that we have to retreat to a
notion of us in them we can't let them
have what we have because we'll destroy
the planet now the problem is I saw it
in my development of this third theory
of the economics of ideas was not what
Malthusian theory suggested about scarce
objects but it was what it emitted which
was this possibility of discovering new
ideas this had been referred to the
process of the accumulation of ideas was
often referred to as technological
change and just like my son Jeff my
colleagues recognized that this could be
the offsetting force but to have a
theory that could satisfy a physicist I
needed to dig down and to what was the
meaning of an idea how could we be price
of be precise about an idea and then use
the accumulation of ideas as a way to
understand technological progress now
one of the key elements of an idea is
that it represents codified knowledge
it's knowledge represented in symbols on
a piece of paper or in
Bent's these days because it's codified
it can be copied and shared and then
used by everybody on earth and by shared
I don't mean the kind of sharing where
we take turns this is the sharing where
everybody can use something like the
Pythagorean theorem at the same time if
we want for example create the kinds of
right angles that we use in construction
now the best way I know to illustrate a
single idea comes from a truly
remarkable paper that my co-recipient
bill wrote in the nineteen of the 1990s
his insight was that we could measure
progress by using not the conventional
units of a dollars worth of purchasing
power today or a euros worth of
purchasing power we could measure output
per person in the kind of units that a
physicist wouldn't recognize lumen hours
now think of a lumen is the light that's
produced by a candle going all the way
back to the pleistocene bill measured
the amount of light that the average
person could get from an hour of work
there's no way for me to improve on his
words from this paper I have performed a
number of experiments with sesame oil
and lamps purportedly dating from Roman
times see the appendix these experiments
provide evidence that an hour's work
today will buy 350,000 times as much
illumination as could be bought in early
Babylonia that's real progress and when
you look at the pattern of progress most
of it comes in the very recent period
the period since the Industrial
Revolution and since the the Scientific
Revolution now in this paper there's one
data point which represents the roughly
tenfold increase in the amount of light
that we could extract from a gas flame
that was the result of burning that
flame inside what was called a mantle
now the my protection did that was what
in the world is a mantle and what's the
physics behind the process whereby it
coaxes ten times as much light out of a
gas flame this picture illustrates the
difference between an open gas flame and
a mantle and it's hard to see but if you
look at a physical mantle what you
notice is that it's a metal cage and
burning flame inside the cage heats up
the metal to the point of incandescent
which means the metal glows with this
bright white light that you see in the
picture now the man who discovered this
welsbach could take that insight and
then put it to use in streetlights all
over the world long before Edison
discovered how to make a wire
incandescent by running electricity
through it but welsbach could share this
idea with everybody in the world who had
access to a gas streetlight because it
was codified knowledge which could then
be spread and was copied all throughout
the world now there's another concept
that I need to flesh out about related
to ideas which is what computer
scientists refer to as combinatorial
explosion if you have a number of
elements that you can combine you have
ten elements and combine them we can
calculate how many combinations can you
make if you have 20 we can calculate
again combinatorial explosion is a
summary of the fact that the number of
combinations explodes as you take more
and more raw different elements that you
can use to combine them so when for
example we think about all the possible
peptides you can make out of amino acids
the there's just immense just
unbelievably large set of
are ya peptides that you can create out
of 50 amino acid pair me no acid units
and this year's chemistry prize is about
methods for creating libraries of all of
these peptides and exploring them using
new new kind of methods including those
motivated by evolution when Wells back
was trying to find the right mix of
metals for his mantle he tried a number
of different metals and mixtures and
again the number of possible mixtures
explodes as you think of more and more
metals so an idea is codified knowledge
about the properties of one from an
almost infinite set of possibilities and
when you define an idea that way it's
immediately obvious that the discovery
of new ideas from these almost infinite
sets of possibilities could offset the
scarce resources implied by the
Malthusian analysis so to understand the
difference this makes look again at this
picture if more light gives these
students the chance to study to go work
in science they may discover something
like the mantle and they may provide a
benefit to us that could more than
offset the costs of additional
mitigation of or avoidance of carbon
emissions so ideas mean that people are
no longer our rivals they can be our
allies and this suggests a very
important possibility that we can take
the set of us and expand it we can draw
a bigger circle include more people
inside us and treat them with the at
least indifference or the small
appreciation that comes from
membership in the set of at the set of
us now this benefit of other people was
a possibility that bill wrote discovered
and model he published in nineteen sixty
nine can arrow another Nobel
prize-winning economist wrote a model
with that same property in nineteen
sixty-two I in the 90s after working out
a theory of growth based on ideas and
along with other economists worked on
results showing that integrating
different regions of the world into a
unified global system where we traded
goods but particularly importantly we
traded ideas this could speed up the
worldwide rate of growth but in a
conversation I had with Bill he said
that he was uncomfortable about this
result that more people could actually
beneficial be beneficial because it was
a theoretical possibility but how did we
know it was true and when I looked at
combining different regions letting them
work with each other
I skirted this issue because in effect
what I was saying is we can let more
people come to this party but they got
to bring their own resources so there
wasn't the same effect of more people
meant less natural resources for each of
us what was astonishing was that work
that emerged around this time including
work by Chad Jones who's here somewhere
but also Ron Lee from demography Michael
creamer another young economist work
showing that from the period of roughly
the Neolithic Revolution to at least the
Scientific Revolution the actual
evolution of humans as a species was
driven by a process of more discoveries
leading to the production of more food
which led to more people who in turn
developed more and more discoveries and
so there was this explosive process of
growth that was in the population that
was proceeding at a rate that was
growing exponentially so this is not
exponential growth this is exponential
growth in the rate of exponential growth
which is the best way to characterize
the behavior of humans up through about
the Industrial Revolution and as Michael
creamer showed and and as was also
implicit in analysis by a diamond in his
book Guns Germs and Steel that the
evolution of at least the carrying
capacity if the number of people varied
across regions that had started from
initials that differences in stocks of
people and differences in the initial
intrinsic carrying capacity so some
regions could take off in terms of
technology and then have this more rapid
growth of people and more growth of
technology others like Australia after
the ice of the ice had melted and there
was no longer a land bridge that
connected them to other people where
technological progress was very limited
but but notice this is an unusual notion
of progress its progress in carrying
capacity but it's not progress in
standards of living because for most of
this period as we got more and more
capacity for producing food what it led
to was more and more people so rapidly
growing people rapidly growing
technology and increases in carrying
capacity but not much improvement in
standards of living and it's really
after the Industrial Revolution at about
the same time as we started to limit our
own fertility in the growth of the
population that we see what I would call
material progress which is growth in
standards of living growth in how much
we have like how much light we can have
now the key point I want to make is that
there's a third notion of progress but I
want to call human progress
progress not in what we have but in who
we are and it's the kind of progress
that comes from seeing other people even
perhaps starting to see other sentient
beings like the the animals we interact
with seeing them as part of us treating
them with at least in difference rather
than malevolence and treating them as
objects of predation
this type of progress in who we are is
even more important than the material
progress and I know that the moral
reasoning suggests that we should be
capable of that kind of moral progress
human progress
even if in some sense it works to our
disadvantage but let's be honest people
are people it's a lot easier to get
people to think of others as allies if
in fact those others actually help them
and this is what the period of explosive
population growth shows on balance it's
better to have more people they are our
allies they are part of us now am I
being Pollyanna ish that's something I
get accused of in saying that we're
capable of this kind of deep human
progress I don't think so
for example we live in cities with
millions of people most of whom are
strangers and we're not threatened by
them and we don't try to attack them and
this is something that our our ancestors
in the Pleistocene could never have
understand could never have understood
but but even more importantly us used to
mean the way that men thought about
other men and we're in the process of a
fundamental change in our human nature
and our making a fundamental improvement
along the lines of human progress
because we now recognize that women
belong as full members of us we're a
long way from full equality in terms of
respect and dignity but the product
direction is unambiguous we've made some
progress on this dimension and the
direction is unambiguous and again this
shouldn't have required any personal
benefit it shouldn't required shouldn't
have required self-interest to
to demand this kind of human progress
but again it helps when people
understand that the discoveries of Marie
Curie or Donna Strickland or Francis
Arnold can actually make our lives
better and that there's a huge advantage
in doubling the number of people who can
contribute to the production of the
ideas from which we all benefit so my my
time is coming to an end
let me just hint at to two practical
policy applications that emerge from
this economics of ideas one is to think
of cities as chances for people
especially in the developing world to
get the benefits of interaction with
other people other people are beneficial
on net in the words of my colleague ed
Glaeser cities make us smarter now in
the coming century we will build more
urban area than we've built we humans
will build more human area than we've
built since the Neolithic Revolution
it'll take only about a hundred years
and then when the pop as the population
stabilizes in this century this project
what my colleague Sally Angel calls the
urbanization project will be done will
have the layouts of the cities that
people will live with forever and if we
lay out the city from the beginning if a
government lays out the city with a plan
that protects some public space that
allows the kind of connectivity you get
when you've got a street that's wide
enough for a bus to drive down and to
make sure that nobody's more than about
a half a kilometre from a bus route that
they could use home to work if you lay
out that space in advance it costs
almost nothing if you try to get it
after completely disorganized unplanned
development it's almost infinitely
costly to get that space I don't think
we'll ever
see anywhere in the future the kind of
experience that Paris went through under
Houseman where it was possible to just
destroy large numbers of buildings move
people and build broad avenues where
they didn't exist before so we have a
chance in the next hundred years at very
low cost to lay the foundation for
successful urbanization that can help
everyone enjoy the benefits of learning
from others but if we take a pass on
this that the opportunity will be gone
and the the entire future will be less
well will generate less material
progress for all the people who could so
much benefit from it the other point I
need to make is that because the
population won't grow after this century
to get to keep getting more and more
ideas we need more people to go into
science and we need to raise the
productivity in science one of the
interesting things that I looked at in
the data about Nobel Prize winners is in
the 1910 to the 1900s the first decade
in the second decade of the 20th century
something like 6% only 6% of the
recipients were from the United States
no I think I think even 3% in the first
20 years then and from 19 the 1930s and
40s it increases to 15 percent after
World War two it approaches more than 50
percent that early development is a sign
of investments the United States made in
a university system that started in the
1860s and it takes time for a commitment
to science to progress to the point
where you have people doing nobel prize
quality science but it's possible and we
could do now new things that helped spur
the same kind of both increase in the
total fraction of the population that is
engaged in discovery and research and
science and we can raise the
productivity of all of those people
there is evidence right now that
productivity in science hasn't
and has been falling as more important
into it but this is something that we
can correct
finally it is true that we face a very
serious challenge with addressing global
warming but it's important to remember
this is a challenge not of the physics
not of nature not of scarce resources
this is a challenge of making a decision
it's like deciding to stick switch to
daylight savings
it's like deciding in Sweden to shift to
driving on the right it's not hard to do
it once you decide what's hard is
deciding and that's what Bill's idea if
the club is about but even within a
country we need to find ways to appeal
to other parts of the human spirit to
persuade us all to make those kinds of
decisions so let me close with
encouragement to young people about what
a fantastic life can come from science
and encouragement to young economists at
a time when the economics profession has
gotten a lot more competitive it's much
tougher to start out as a young person
than it was when I was a graduate
student or bill was but remember that
there is an enormous opportunity in
economics to start to explore these
broader notions of progress the broader
side of human nature that it includes
the kind of things that William Faulkner
talked about in his Nobel speech love
and honor pity and pride and compassion
and sacrifice economics will be much
more relevant when we can take account
of all those and we'll have a better
idea about why is it that we can
sometimes appeal to sacrifice and people
respond because this is what we'll need
so let me close by expressing my deep
appreciation for this system of prizes
that Alfred Nobel established and that
the Nobel Foundation has sustained a
system for celebrating all the types of
intellectual inquiry that emerged from
the period we call the Enlightenment and
remember there's a reason we call it the
Enlightenment
so yes let there be light
let there be light in daily life but let
there be light too in our spirits and
our souls thank you
yes it means me love
I guess you can shake hands or something